[Musica]
a chiunque facessi la domanda quelle
scienziato ha in mente quasi tutti
direbbero un nome maschile tranne mio
figlio batte 8 anni al quale se si
chiede qual è il tuo scienziato
preferito vi dice sempre la mia mamma da
bambina avevo una passione sfegatata per
due rockstar
una era leonardo da vinci e l'altra era
albert einstein quindi in
un'appassionata di tutti gli scienziati
in generale di sappiamo tutti e
conoscevo tutte le loro opera volta
meucci marconi è di song bat
se mi fermo un attimo a pensare e ad
analizzare tutti questi nomi mi rendo
conto che sono tutti i nomi maschili e
le donne ci sono tantissime 3 per fra
tutte quante rita levi montalcini
margherita hack e me li curi oppure per
entrare nel mio settore io sono un
informatico a da loris e ad hanover e se
stata la prima donna programmatrice o
meglio l'unica e prima donna che ha
creato la programmazione informatica è
nata dalla doman informatica mi spiace
voi uomini e donne
quindi perché quando cominciamo a
pensare al nome di scienziati
immaginiamo nomi maschili per un
fenomeno che si chiama serio tipo di
genere
io sono un inventrice o meglio un master
in berton che cos'è un master in mente
un po come masterchef masterchef crea
nuove ricette basandosi su ingredienti
commestibili il masso invento invece
crea ricette invenzioni basandosi su
ingredienti di tecnologici essere un
master inventor 0 un'informatica
oggigiorno una donna in questi campi è
facile no non lo era un tempo non lo è
neanche adesso
anche perché c'è in giro una strana
teoria per la quale le competenze di una
donna ha perso la tecnologia sono
inversamente proporzionale all'altezza
dei suoi tacchi a spillo
quindi io non dovrei essere per niente
portata
eppure da 25 anni mi occupo di creare
soluzioni progetti per accelerare la
trasformazione
digitale sono andata dirigente in un
azienda a presentare il mio progetto mi
ho disegnato da me sull'intelligenza
artificiale
andiamo da questa questa azienda
entriamo con un insieme di miei colleghi
tutti maschi le persone che non in
questa sala erano tutti uomini
mi chiedono di accomodarmi in un
angolino o sopra uno sgabello in attesa
che loro parlassero di cose serie chi
non sembrino sicuramente non avrei
capito né un certo punto parte l'agenda
della giornata
sullo schermo è il primo a parlare era
proprio questo master invento dottor
ferrara e qualcuno fa ma dov'è e io alzo
la mano e faccio sono io perché non
hanno già ottenuto un po lo stupore ma
soprattutto l'amministratore delegato mi
guarda e fa male una donna ho risposto
nessuno consapevole
ero andato bene perché comunque con
ciottolo chiuso poi abbiamo superato un
attimo leo lo shock di vedere una donna
parlare di temi informatici insomma non
è facile essere donna ed essere
apprezzata in questi questi campi dovevo
combattere gli stereotipi ma lo
sterotipo non è soltanto perché l'uomo
pensa che una donna non sia portata per
per l'informatica spesso anche la donna
pensa di non essere portata per
l'informatica e allora dobbiamo cercare
di avvicinare le donne verso queste
scienze e io amo
direi che dovevo combattere gli
stereotipi con una grande donna ha
combattuto un grande stereotipo la mamma
di leonardo da vinci
lui nato nel 1452 ed ero un figlio
illegittimo nato da piero da vinci il
famosissimo taglio di una famiglia
ricchissima e da caterina non si hanno
molte informazioni su di lei forse era
una serva forse era una contadina
oppure ma soprattutto non sappiamo
neanche se fosse italiano o meno
sappiamo di certo che era una donna
bellissima e molto intelligente
arriva dunque di un anno da vinci non
doveva crescere nella famiglia da vinci
per quell'epoca leonardo da vinci era
dove valence doveva crescere con una
mamma serva o contadina non sarebbe mai
dovuto essere accettato da una famiglia
da vinci invece la mamma riesce a
combattere questo stereotipo fa
conoscere dopo qualche anno dalla
nascita di questo bambino
leonardo al nonno che se ne innamora e
finalmente lo accolgono finalmente al
cognome giocata vinci e questo bambino
cresce in questa famiglia e soprattutto
a una formazione scolastica che
altrimenti non avrebbe mai avuto
se abbiamo leonardo da vinci oggi è
perché la mamma era una persona talmente
smartdate ha superato non solo tipo
credo incredibile le immaginate un mondo
una vita senza leonardo da vinci le
opere di leonardo da vinci
io non me l'immagino e soprattutto
mostrano immagini da meno il lusso senza
la monna lisa
domando vinci tutti riconosciamo come un
grandissimo scienziato abbiamo visto
oggi un sacco di sue opere ma poi è lui
e rapportati simo per per queste materie
anzi io lui lo definirei un nerd
sapete che cos'è un hard nerd nnn è un
ragazzo passa non sa goffo ma il vestito
che ha però una grandissima passione per
la tecnologia e allora perché noi
pensiamo che sia così perché i media ce
lo presentano in questa maniera
televisione pubblicità film oppure
possiamo andare su internet fanno una
bellissima ricerca definizione di nerd
il risultato nerd sostantivo giovane e
già la maschio giovane di modesta
presenza fisica dall'aspetto
insignificante che compensano scarsa
aderenza e le fissazioni che ne derivano
con una passione smisurata per la
tecnologia ora a me scarsa avvenenza
presenza insignificante non me l'ha mai
detto nessuno quindi vorrei un attimo
parlare con questo autore o
quest'attrice per me non fa differenza
nerd non è in questo nerd è per esempio
come dicevo prima leonardo da vinci nord
vince un dardo perché lui era
appassionato di tutte le tecnologie
maniera leonardo vincerà un bellissimo
uomo molto affascinante in gambissima
aveva un sacco di seguito era molto
social
oggigiorno sarebbe impazzito con i
nostri social poi vi dico quale secondo
me è il suo preferito non doveva vincere
un artista e mi appassionava quando ero
bambina ancora di più mi appassiona
adesso perché lui era un precursore di
indossando i nostri giorni lui ha creato
progettato il primo robot la toma
cavaliere nel 1495 oppure lui ha creato
disegnato molto probabilmente
bisogna ancora confermarlo alla prima il
primo calcolatore nel 1967 a madrid è
stato trovato sono stati trovati dei
manoscritti degli schizzi che perder
quali pensino che sia stati disegnati da
leonardo da vinci e per il quale sono
state anche fatte dei prototipi 3d di
recente e ha creato questo calcolatore
ma ancora prima e meglio migliorando la
vinci amava riprodursi ma amava farsi
dagli autoritratti e si girava il suo
viso
nelle opere che dipingeva o nelle
sculture che lui faceva e lo faceva
spessissimo sulla l'ultima cena
addirittura si pensa che due dei
discepoli abbiano la sua faccia
insomma non amava che gli altri non
riprendessero perché lui era molto
fissato la sua bellezza doveva avere
certi canoni voleva essere ripreso una
certa maniera
faceva gli schizzi e di vita va a chi
voleva fare lo voleva riprendere secondo
me sarebbe stato un grandissimo moderno
oggi e soprattutto secondo me in sel
figli ambientati leonardo da vinci il
suo strumento tool social preferito
sicuramente sarebbe stato instagram con
tutti i disegni che faceva lì doveva
mostrare tutti quanti
insomma essere un nerd una persona un
artista un vero artista già stessa che
fa crea delle opere dal nulla
lo scrittore crea un'opera da una pagina
bianca
il pittore script crea un'opera dal
latte e labianca informatico crea la sua
opera dal monitor bianco quindi lo
informatico è un artista e poi
scusate ma medico può essere non sia un
uomo o una donna
il commercialista sia uno nuovo e una
donna l'architetto sia un uomo che una
donna
l'informatico può essere sia un uomo e
una donna non ci sono particolari limiti
caratteriali concettuali mentali fisici
per cui una donna non possa essere
portata per queste materie
e allora per fare ciò ci sono tantissimi
progetti che cercano di aiutare le
ragazze ad avvicinarsi a queste
discipline
uno fra tutti il mio progetto si chiama
progetto nardò dove l'acronimo di non è
roba per donne e cosa facciamo portiamo
queste ragazze di 15 e 16 anni
all'interno dei laboratori di
informatica dell'università aprono le
loro porte fanno entrare queste ragazze
si facciamo assaggiare le studentesse
cosa significhi essere un vero
informatico le loro si appassionano e
finalmente capiscono che forse
dovrebbero studiare informatica
da quel momento in poi cosa cerchiamo di
fare noi cerchiamo di orientare le
ragazze verso gli studi scientifici
affinché loro possano immaginare e
disegnare e creare e costruire il loro
futuro
sul campo della tecnologia perché
assolutamente quello che vogliamo
dimostrare che le ragazze di oggi sono
le da vinci di domani grazie
[Applauso]